tom brady
is uh
known as
one of the greatest quarterbacks of all
time uh still one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl today obviously
uh one super bowl etc he i need to start
this entire thing off with tom brady is
0-2
against eli manning in the super bowl
and the new york giants beat him twice
right facts just just stating it that's
fine it's true shout out uh saquon
whatever it's cool uh anytime either of
those teams no he was naive
he was not but
promised me saguan promised me that we
were going to win a super bowl he said
that's the plan boss no problem we're
going to win super bowl that that's all
that matters uh so planet tell us about
tom brady and uh maybe give us a little
bit of his background and kind of how we
get to today and then we can break down
the business behind him all right so tom
brady
um
is referred to the greatest uh
quarterback of all time but that's
besides the point um he after 20 seasons
with uh the patriots he became a free
agent and he signed with the tampa bay
buccaneers not buccaneers how i wanted
to call them buccaneers
leading them to the super bowl for the
first time since their appearance in
2003 but he was not an obvious success
story apparently in high school where he
was known as tommy brady uh he was a
much better baseball player than he was
a football player so then when he told
his coaches he was actually going to
play football they were like wait what
he started as a quarterback on his
junior varsity high school football team
and his first game he was sacked 15
times
and his old coach joe hession he said it
was the worst beating of my life and it
made you want to walk off and go to a
bar and quit
um but brady had something that his
peers obviously didn't he became kind of
like a student of the sport he lived and
breathed and loved uh football and uh
it's really interesting it says that uh
basically he started as an aspiring
football player with a chip on his
shoulder determined to prove people
wrong but today it's less about proving
other people wrong and it's more about
proving himself right and i think that
that's why he went to the buccaneers to
show the world like i don't necessarily
need the patriots uh to be successful
and um here i wrote something about like
the brady mindset is very much about he
says true competitors are the ones who
always play to win so there's people
in football and in life who play to win
and others who play to not lose and it's
a it's a small mindset shift in that one
is a mentality of being on the offense
and the other ones like being on the
defense he's like don't even play if
you're not playing to win um and then
the other thing that's really
interesting is uh he does brain
exercises for five to ten minutes a day
to keep his brain sharp and his
cognitive function sharp um he says how
can i build up my brain strength so that
whenever i do take a hit there's a
little bit of armor there the games keep
me sharp uh and he treats his brain very
much like a muscle and he has a whole
you know program of
diet nutrition exercise things that he
does that we can talk about
joe what's the business behind this dude
he's worth what 250 million dollars
himself
yeah so he's unique because uh you know
as as pauline was mentioning like he
wasn't a highly regarded draft pick
coming in he was just we have the photo
i i think we do do we there he is yeah
infamous photo
at the combine
damn yeah all right i don't know what
called uh
nfl
tom brady that is that is a dad bod
right there pre-dad yeah i had 20.
i was killing it
20 single mochi yeah
listen by the way everyone lasted this
photo it worked out listen you you're a
gangster if you go from this photo
everyone making fun of you so what's he
got six seven super bowl rings whatever
that's fine all right keep going yeah so
the i mean the thing is so he was a six
round draft pick uh the probability for
those that follow the nfl of a starting
quarterback starting more than like two
or three years in that late of the round
is less than one percent supposedly so
just uh drastically outperformed his
draft position obviously the greatest
quarterback in the nfl history but he's
made uh he'll probably end his career
with about 300 million dollars in salary
he's got 250 now but the biggest benefit
that he's had is his wife uh giselle is
worth 500 million so he has uh
traditionally taken less money with the
patriots which allowed them to win so
the nfl is a salary cap sport there's
only a certain amount of money that each
team can spend in a given year and he
was able to take significantly less than
each of the other best starting
quarterbacks in the league and give
additional salary to some of his
teammates right so they estimate that he
earned about uh sixty thousand dollars
less than he would have uh with the
patriots so he gave that money back
essentially to the team and allowed them
to distribute to other players so six
million dollars a lot of money helps
when your wife is worth 500 million
dollars though um and then yeah like the
business side of it he's he's done a
bunch of endorsements and he's more
recently uh he's big with under armour
uh a bunch of other kind of like smaller
name endorsements that pay him cash but
he started to take equity in some of
these companies that he does
endorsements with there's a mattress
company that uh he has equity in there's
a a sunglass company that he has equity
in our eyeglass company that he's equity
in uh but then he had he just launched
autograph so uh autograph is an nft
platform he partnered with draftkings
and essentially what he did which was
unique was instead of going out and
going to these athletes and saying hey
let's create nfts for you in this
digital art and we will go out and
promote it and sell it and you'll get a
cut he signed exclusive intellectual
property deals with them in the digital
world so he went up to uh tiger woods
wayne gretzky naomi osaka himself and he
signed exclusive deals where they were
given their nft rights over to autograph
the company he raised a bunch of money
signed a deal with uh draftkings to
launch the marketplace and now they're
selling out uh i think he sold like 1500
of them in five minutes on the launch of
himself right and maybe each one's a
hundred dollars five hundred dollars a
thousand dollars but you can see over
time uh when you start to look at it
from the exclusive standpoint where they
have the ip for all these some of the
best athletes in the world that it
becomes really valuable so he owns that
company he's an owner of the company uh
i don't know what kind of equity
percentage he ended up with but that's
where he's really going to make a ton of
money right so he has tb12 which is the
nutritional business and his coaching
business uh it's going well i think they
have like 50 or 60 employees now which
is growing and and they're uh have a few
different locations open but when you
look at it from like a scaling
perspective
look nfts i don't know some people think
they're great some people think they're
terrible i think the market will
eventually decide on that but if it
becomes a success and it's something
that's here for the long run uh and it's
an asset that draftkings can build a fan
base around then you can quickly see how
that business becomes much more valuable
than anything he's probably done in the
past is tom brady better at football or
at business if you look at the
tb12 what's the valuation of that
business and then you look at autograph
if he came out of the gate and it's
valued in the nine figures which means
that he probably has made more money on
paper from autograph than he has uh you
know in a long time playing football yep
is he a better business person than he's
a football player football but he
focuses more time on football right now
i have a feeling yeah i mean he's
look he's he's definitely a better
football player i don't know
how do you measure how do you measure
i'm not saying he's not success do we
measure it by
championships and rings which there
isn't an equivalent of in in uh business
or do we measure it by money made no but
go ahead go ahead i was just gonna say
he would never be as successful of a
businessman i don't think if he wasn't
first a football player and had all that
success maybe mark wahlberg was an
underwear model and a rap star and then
he became a successful business person
yeah movie star
in the context of uh tb12 is it's
they're now transitioning to an online
business but it's a brick and mortar
they own two retail locations and people
would come in for training it's not a
billion dollar business at all so when
you think about in that context like he
just started autographed literally like
three months ago they raised a bunch of
money which inflated the valuation and
like it's a new market so no one knows
really kind of how valuable it is in the
long run so that just started he's 45
years old he's won all these super bowls
he's done all this stuff he's made
hundreds of millions of dollars he's
clearly uh better on the on the football
front than he has business football
enables that maybe over time he'll be
able to use his brand and his image to
do all these different things within the
business world but he hasn't ever had he
hasn't really had a significant win yet
on the on the business side because he
can't sell any of the equity in
autograph right so it's to be determined
kind of where that value ends up it
could be a multi-billion dollar business
or it could be zero right we we have to
see how that plays out uh and then tb12
is still like a relatively small
business when it comes to uh the course
of his career and the monies he's earned
is tom brady a billionaire
no no no i i think well his family
probably might be no no no no i i think
no i think tom brady is a billionaire
and here and here's my logic for why tom
brady's a billionaire one tb12 if he was
to sell it today and he would sell it
with the rights and he would continue to
support it etc fetches a nine-figure
evaluation doesn't matter what the
actual underlying business is somebody's
buying it because it comes with the ip
of tom brady and that is nearly
priceless two is autograph nine figure
business already we saw the sales that
they were able to drive right out of the
gate right and so my guess is that if he
was to go and sell that business today
he's pulling in 500 million dollars to a
billion dollars just by selling that
alone
three is if you look at all of the
memorabilia et cetera like that entire
business where they're actually selling
this stuff that is again probably not a
nine-figure business probably
eight-figure business and then when you
look on top of it he himself from his
earnings on the field is what 250
million dollars give or take so you
start to look at it you only have to
come up with 750 million dollars more of
equity value that includes the things
he's built but including any of the
investment 250 million dollars doesn't
count towards you it's like he he paid
taxes on that
that's 125 gone well half of it well i
don't think he's paying 50 tax but yeah
but
my point was right now tb12 last year
had 20 employees it's not a billion
dollar business because he would never
sell it with ip it's just never going to
be that valuable however the real win is
the real win is if he can build
autograph into something right where
it's nfts take off it's a massive
business fanatic spills out a platform
draftkings builds out a platform tickets
start handing out nfts uh tickets at
events coming nfts with all this stuff
right so if that builds into like a real
marketplace that's where his big win is
going to be tb12 look they had 20
employees they're expanding but it's not
uh he he would never sell with the ip
it's not a billion dollar business maybe
a hundred million dollars i don't know
depends on what the sales are they've
never set them publicly and like the
whispers are that it was never like you
know that big of a thing my point is
less about somebody's not buying tb12
because they're getting cash flow
they're buying tb12 because they have
tom brady and fitness and they go and
they would be the ones to scale it et
cetera so i'm not saying it's a billion
dollar business by itself but i
definitely think that it's a 100 plus
million dollar business and then
autograph i mean what who does he have
uh he has tiger woods he's got naomi
osaka he's got himself yeah derek jeter
and i'm osaka tony hawk uh tiger woods
and wayne gretzky and he has exclusive
ip rights for all of those folks around
nfts yeah i mean what
again
i can't say too much because i actually
know how much it's worth but like it's
not worth ten dollars no right
and so it's like when you think about
that size of the business it's it's not
hard to see how
tom brady maybe he's not a billionaire
right this side well he owns bitcoin so
yeah he might be soon
if he isn't already maybe uh is not only
maybe he's not a billionaire right this
second but in the next couple of years i
don't think it's completely out of reach
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it